les partisans des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle commence à s'impatienter
depuis plusieurs jours des centaines
d'indigènes équatorien manifestent dans
les rues de la capitale quito pour
soutenir leurs favoris à la présidence
de l'équateur et à coup perez selon les
résultats encore provisoires du premier
tour publiés ce jeudi cet avocat
écologistes arrive troisième du scrutin
avec 19,42 % des voix il est devancé de
peu par le conservateur guillermo olaso
crédité de 19,72 % des suffrages et donc
pour l'instant qualifié pour le second
tour mais devant ses fidèles
yakou perez dénonce une manipulation ils
commettent une fraude flagrante et ce
qu'ils font c'est laisser endommager
gravement la démocratie la démocratie
actuelle est une caricature un théâtre
de mauvais goût cela m'attriste
terriblement ils ne veulent pas les
votes pour yacou perez ils veulent tout
un projet tout un rêve tout un espoir
que les équatoriens avait le candidat
indigènes réclamant recomptage des voix
dans plusieurs provinces dont les quatre
qui ont le plus grand nombre d'électeurs
au premier tour une demande soutenue par
son adversaire guillermo olaso de son
côté andrey saros large vainqueur du
premier tour avec plus de 32 % des voix
exprimées demande à ses rivaux de garder
leur calme
nous appelons tous les acteurs
politiques impliqués dans ce processus
électoral à être patient à agir avec
prudence et nous appelons à la
non-violence à maintenir une situation
pacifique
tous les autres points à résoudre dans
le cadre du processus électoral devrait
être réglée dans le respect des
principes démocratiques et des
mécanismes institutionnels approprié
alors que le conseil national électoral
n'a pas encore publié des résultats
définitifs
la mission d'observation envoyée par
l'organisation des états américains
recommandent elle aussi aux candidats de
faire preuve de responsabilité et à la
population d'attendre les résultats dans
le calme
en attendant le conseil national
électoral est protégé par l'armée
envoyées en renfort